Now let's look at the process of how light is converted to data.
And look at the digital process in parallel to what we just looked at
which was the process for doing it for films.
The foundational device, foundational technology if you will, for
converting light to data is a CCD, right, Charge-Coupled Device.
It's an electronic device that basically converts electrical charges into
a digital value.
So in essence, a pixel on a output that comes out from
the charge coupled device, or a CCD, is basically, are different capacitors.
Which can work and store incoming photons as electron charges.
Photons are the ones that basically have photoelectric value.
And once they have these capacitors these are converted into electron charges.
And it's this electron charge which is stored and given a digital value.
It's important to note here that Dr. Boyle and Dr. Smith in 1969.
While they were working at Bell Labs invented the concept of a CCD,
a Charge-Coupled Device.
And of course, they were awarded with the Nobel prize in 2009.
And actually you know, being person who works in the photography field this was
an amazing piece of technology that they have developed.
>From 1969 to 2009 and of course it's one of the most common pieces of
technology in our homes, our businesses.
And everybody has one nowadays is basically a camera that is
somehow the other related to this concept of charge coupled device.